des clichés de végétaux transformés en
tableaux impressionnistes en mutation
l'oeuvre s'intitule effet de soi lors de
plusieurs séjours à chaumont l'artiste
italien davide quayola a photographié
les jardins du château avant de traiter
les clichés à l'aide d'un logiciel qu'il
a lui même développé la musique est
aussi de sa composition
je voulais créer un procédé informatique
qui pourrait à la fois imité le courant
impressionniste et en même temps aller
plus loin que le traitement humain
j'aime jouer avec l'idée de virtuosité
il ya un humaine
l'oeuvre se réfère à un mouvement
pictural historique mais propose aussi
d'autres manières digital d'étudier le
sujet
cette partie supérieure de l est du
château abrite est historiquement les
chambres de bonnes
longtemps laissé à l'abandon en proie
aux infiltrations laitages a été
réaménagé et rouvre au public pour la
première fois depuis les années 30
comme la charpente est apparu qu'il y
avait un volume extraordinaire je me
suis dit qu'une galerie numérique ça
serait tout à fait en écho à eauze
estang ce que nous avons déjà menées
dans ce domaine on est dans le rêve pas
du patrimoine des murs anciens des
oeuvres aux anciennes et puis on regarde
vers notre temps et quand on a un chose
pourra faire le pont entre le passé le
présent et le futur on joue tout à fait
dans ce rôle de centre d'art et nature
l'inauguration de cette galerie digital
arrive à point nommé à quelques semaines
de l'ouverture de la saison d'art à
chaumont début avril une quinzaine
d'artistes internationaux seront exposés
dans les galeries et les jardins du
château